einheit von mir
ja viele geheimtipp zum beispiel es
nicht was schon abgelaufen ist guckt
immer drauf ob es schon abgelaufen ist
weil manchmal findet man früher schon
sachen die sind vom letzten jahren ist
gerade gestern passiert margarine
gegessen hey da war ja doch schimmel
drauf achtet man darauf ob das
abgelaufen ist aber mein wirklicher
greift probiert mal trost mit salami
drauf und darüber bisschen othello kein
spaß probiert worden entschuldigung er
sein roter teppich ausgelegt worden ich
muss mal einen draufsetzen probiert mal
matthias häring mit nutella
es ist speziell aber es geht ihr könnt
ja man kann hilft er schmeckt nicht da
koch das werk das ist interessant das
ist also bitte und sagt man wie es
geschmeckt hat und aber natürlich auch
wie hier die salami in der celler wir
sehen was made by sachen dass du liebst
mainz mein schmeckt besser meinte er ich
weiß nicht mehr was matthias häring ist
das ist das ist der des total kitschig
und darauf nutella es geht
ich habe es einmal gemacht sondern mich
ein bisschen an tourbus folgt die bitte
fast kennst du tust haben ein faible so
okay weil ich das zu sagt mir was das
ist in den kommentaren der probier's mal
und dann sage ich ihnen ob sie denn
geschmeckt hat